we need you to come in let me picture  where do you want me I'm such a huge fan  of the Black Widow and I love playing  this character and for me suiting up  again was just pretty exciting the Black  Widow when we first find her is  recruiting the team doctor we need you  to come in what if I say no I'll  persuade you Black Widow is just so apt  and so gifted that we figured she should  be part of the team I'm bringing the  party to you I don't see how that's a  party I think all of these characters  are so reluctant superheroes in a sense  big manners suit armor take that away  what are you a genius billionaire  playboy philanthropist all of these  characters coming together in one world  it's very exciting Avengers  it's what we call ourselves Earth's  Mightiest Heroes  rated pg-13